[Müzik]
Ben beyin cerrahıyım nörobilimciyim Tıp
Fakültesi Dekanlığı yapıyorum ve son 10
yılda da hem avrupa bilim sanat
akademisinde hem de Dünya Sanat bilim
akademisinde beyinle ilişkili yapılan
çalışmaların
üyesiyim ve son 10 yılda Biz Beyin nasıl
çalışıyor Beyin nasıl düşünce üretiyor
sorusuna yanıt ararken elde ettiğimiz
sonuçlar yavaş yavaş bize
yaşam nedir Biz bu Ağın içerisinde hangi
noktadayız gibi sorulara da benzer
matematikle yanıt verebileceğimiz
sevgisini uyandırdı ve Şimdi sizlerle
onları paylaşacağım
esasında konuşmanın konusu şu nasıl daha
iyi ve güzel bir dünya yaratabiliriz
hepimizin esas amacı bu ve ben de buna
bir beyin bilimci gözüyle bakacağım
Çünkü
içinde Olduğumuz bu Newton Bacon descart
kültürünün bu uygarlığın ki bu
uygarlığın hakkında vermek lazım insan
ömrü 38 yıl iken ortalama şimdi
biliyorsunuz 80'li yıllara falan ulaştı
iyi Bir yerdeyiz Ama içinde bulunduğumuz
sorunlara yanıt bulmakta zorluk
çekiyoruz Korona döneminde Bunu gördük
Corona insan zihninin gelişme hızını
gerçekten çok hızlandırdı ve bizim insan
merkezli anlayışımızdan yavaş yavaş
yaşam merkezli bir anlayışa doğru bir
geçiş süreci gerçekten hızlandı
İklim Değişikliği var fakirlik var gelir
dağılımında eşitsizlik var ve gerçekten
de nasıl daha iyi ve güzel bir dünya
yaratabiliriz sorusuna yanıt vermekte
zorluk çekiyoruz İşte bu soruya yanıt
arayanları Biraz önce dinlediniz Herkes
kendi penceresinden Bu soruya bir yanıt
bulma çabası içerisinde
henüz şey bana göre en azından var olan
en güzel şey insan beyni neden çünkü
düşünüyor yani benim bütün bu
yolculuğumun sebebi hep Şu soru oldu
hala Tüylerim de kendi diken oluyor bu
soruyu sorduğum zaman nasıl oluyor da bu
et bu 1500 gramlık bu bu organ sanat
yaratıyor bilim yaratıyor düşünüyor
zihin yaratıyor Dolayısıyla 2012'de
dünya
önce Avrupa Sanat bilim akademisine
başladı dedik ki; Madem ki böyle bir
yapı var biyolojik enformasyon işleyen
bir sistem bu biyolojik
enformasyonla bağlantısı sağlık ağı
içerisinde 100 trilyon Ağa var Öyleyse
dedik biz
300 milyar bilgisayarı bir araya
getirsek her biri 10-15.000 başka
bilgisayarla bağlantılandırsak Bu bir
zihin üretebilir mi ya da biz böyle bir
modellemeyi bugünkü bilgisayarlarla
yapabilir miyiz ve böylelikle yaklaşık
120 bilim insanı bu konuyla ilişkili
farklı farklı açılardan çalışma süreci
başladı Avrupa'daki insan beyin Projesi
ve Amerika Birleşik devletleri'ndeki
insan connectom projesi çerçevesinde ve
2015 yılında ilk kez insanlık tarihinde
ilk defa Beyin nasıl düşünce üretiyor
sorusuna bir video yanıt elde ettik
Burada gördüğünüz şey bir deney
hayvanının hipokampus beyninin
karar verme anındaki videosu bu bu
gerçek bir gerçek bir görüntü burada
hayvanın kafesinin kenarına bir su
koyuyorsunuz hayvan bir karar veriyor
Ben bu suya Gideyim mi gitmeyeyim mi ve
o karar verme anında Burada gördüğünüz
36.000 nöron var yani bilinebile bir
tanesi
bir milyon nöron demektir Dolayısıyla
burada 36.000 liranın karar verme
anındaki görüntüsünü izliyorsunuz ilk
kez düşüncenin görüntüsü Tabii bu
2015'te oldu ve bunun arkasındaki
matematik ortaya çıkmaya başladı yani
nasıl düşünüyor sorusunun yanıtını
bulmak için bizim bir matematiğe
ihtiyacımız olduğunu anladık bu
matematik yeni bir matematikti ve nasıl
ki
like list döneminde her bilim kendi
matematiğiyle birlikte geliyor Bunun
örnekleri çok ve Bu soruda kendi
matematiğiyle birlikte geldi bugün Artık
buna enformasyon matematiği diyoruz ve
Anladık ki esas bizim incelememiz
gereken şey nöronlar değil yani bir
bütüne baktığınız zaman o bütünü Biz hep
bugün Newton back'in tekrar çocukları
olarak Hep onun Yapı taşlarını
inceliyoruz yani maddeye inceliyorsak
atomu inceliyoruz bir binaya bakıyorsak
işte onun Yapı taşlarını inceliyoruz
ekonomiye bakıyorsak para birimlerine
bakıyoruz Bu da bana Refik Anadolu'nun
hediye ettiği bir hedefti ve anlamaya
başladık ya esas esas iş bağlantısallık
ve esas yapmamız gereken şey anlamamız
gereken bir şey beyni oluşturan
nöronlardan ziyade onların birbiriyle
oluşturduğu bu bağlantı sağlık ağı ve bu
da bize yeni bir matematiğin kapısını
açtı esasında Biz bunu beyin
cerrahisinde biliyoruz bakın burada
solda gördüğünüz
nöronal kök hücreleri koyduğunuz zaman
oluşan beynin görüntüsü hemen A
yapıyorlar hemen bağlantısallık
kuruyorlar Aynen bizim şu anda yapmaya
çalıştığımız gibi Ama biz farklı bir
enformasyon biçimini kullanıyoruz orada
farklı bir enformasyon var ve bir kez bu
enformasyon bağlantısallıkla oluştuktan
Sonra onun için de düşünce kendi
yollarıyla Ee kendi Ee formlarını
patenlerini desenlerini örüntülerini ya
da Network hepsi aynı anlamda
kullanıyorum
Dolayısıyla soru şu Nasıl oluyor da bu
et düşünce üretiyor şimdi bulduğumuz şey
bulduğumuz sonuç esasında şöyle basite
indir diyeyim
bütüne bakıyorsunuz nedir bu bütün beyin
100 milyar nörondan oluşan beyit ve hep
bugüne kadar yaptığımız şey nöron
çalışıyoruz Halbuki Anladık ki esas
işliyor Onda değil Esas iş nöronların
oluşturduğu bu bağlantısallık alanında
çünkü bütün onu oluşturan parçaların
aritmetik toplamından fazla işte bu
fazlalık nereden geliyor Çünkü bu
termodinamiğin ikinci yasasına aykırı
bir şey bu fazlalığı nereden geldiğine
ait artık elimizde bir matematik var ve
bakın basite indirgemek için söylüyorum
Burada 12 tane nöron olduğunu düşünün ve
bu 12 nöron size bir şey anlatıyor olsun
ve buradaki ilk gördüğünüz üçgenler Bu
sistemin ismi bu dörtgenler soyadı ve
oluşturacağı bu yıldızda ait olduk
Kurumu temsil etsin ve bu enformasyonu
Siz bu bağlantısallıktan alıyorsunuz ve
eğer biz bu Bir Minik beyinse 12
nörondan oluşan bu beynin bize anlattığı
anlattığı bir bilgi var bir enformasyon
var ve Biz bugüne kadar hep bir
Bilinmeze bir bütüne baktığımız zaman
onu anlayabilmek için onu temsil
ettiğine inandığımız Yapı taşlarına
indirgeyip o Yapı taşlarını inceliyordu
hatamız burada ama bu insan aklının
normal gelişim süreci şimdi Artık yavaş
yavaş anlıyor anlıyoruz ki Herhangi bir
bilinmezi incelemek için esas olarak
yapılması gereken şey onu parçalara
ayırıp parç bunları incelemek değil Bu
parçaların birbiriyle olan ilişkisini ve
parçaların bütününe bütünün parçayla
ilişkisini incelemek lazım Çünkü
nöronlar bu birazdan bahsedeceğim
enformasyon matematiği içerisinde bir
zihin oluşturuyorlar zihin dediğimiz şey
bu et olan biyolojik enformasyon sistemi
beyin dediğimiz bu biyolojik enformasyon
sisteminin
yaşam dediğimiz en geniş enformasyon
kodlama bütünlüğü içerisinde oluşturduğu
bir bir enformasyon bu
ve tekrar o
36.000 34 bin nöron tekrar dönüyorum bu
nöronlara baktığımız zaman aynen bu 12
nörona baktığınız gibi baktığımızı
düşünelim ve ortaya çıkardık ki bu
36.000 nöron öyle bir bağlantı sağlık
adıyla bir araya geliyor ki bu
bu 36 bin nöronun verdiği bir karar var
işte bu kararın matematiği bu bunun
matematiğini bilmemize şu an için gerek
yok Ama bunun bir matematiği var ilk kez
düşüncenin nasıl oluştuğuna dair Elimize
bir matematik var tabii bunu anladığımız
zaman esasında sevinelim mi üzülelim mi
Onu da bilmek zor Neden Çünkü buradaki
sistem 36.000 ona ait olan bir matematik
yani geride ne kadar var 100 milyar
eksikse 36.000 ve Anladık ki
elimizdeki bilgisayarlar değil
öngörülebilir gelecekteki bilgisayarlar
da beynin modellemesini yapmaktan çok
uzakta O nedenle hep başka modellemeler
üzerinde ilerlemeye başladık Ama olsun
bir defa artık kapıya ayağımızı
koymuştuk ve kapıdan bilmediğimiz farklı
bir dünyanın ışığı gelmeye başladı Çünkü
artık elimizde bir matematik var düşünce
nedir diye ya da Beyin nasıl zihin
üretiyor sorusuna artık verebileceğimiz
ya da bugün çalışabileceğimiz
modelleyebileceğimiz zihin nasıl
oluşuyor sorusunu yeni bir modelleme ile
yanıt verebileceğimiz daha önce
bilmediğimiz yeni bir matematik var Bu
Matematik 2015'ten bu yana hızla gelişti
2015'ten yana bu yana bütün amel
ödülleri filtreleri geçen seneki fizik
ödülleri bu seneki fizik ödülleri Bir
hafta önce açıklanan hepsi enformasyon
matematiğine verildi Hepsi bu olarak
ve ben bu slaytı 2016'da kullanıyordum
ve diyordum ki bakın yaşam dediğimiz bu
sistem bir araya gelmiş bir enformasyon
kodlama sisteminin bütünlüğü Çünkü bunu
Biz beyinden böyle öğreniyoruz
ve bizim yeni bir matematiğe ihtiyacımız
var bizim var olan matematiğimiz Teldeki
kuşların matematiği sıfırıncı dakikada
kaçı var 1 dakikada kaçı kondu Oysa
diyorduk bizim ihtiyacımız olan şey
Teldeki kuşların durağanlığının
matematiği değil Bize gerekli olan
buradaki kuş sürüsünün birinci kuşun
ikinci ile ikincinin bir milyonuyla
ilişkisini bize anlatan bir matematiğe
ihtiyacımız var ve bu matematiğin
esasında başlangıcı Taha 1850'lere
dayalı bir Bayezid matematik diye bir
matematik Ama bu çok gelişti artık ve bu
artık kocaman bir enformasyon matematik
adını aldı biz Böylelikle yaşamın
içerisindeki Bu buraya bir araya gelmiş
kodlama sistemlerini sosyolojik olaylar
dahil
beynin nasıl zihin üretiyor sorusuna
yanıt vermedeki modellememiz gibi
matematik bir modelleme ile anlayabilir
durumdayız 2016'da bunu konuşurken
2018'de Avrupa bilim sanat akademisinden
de dostum George paracesy bu yazıyı
yazdı ve Burada gördüğünüz şu
soldan üstten en üstteki formül Aynen F
= Ema gibi aynen e eşittir gibi sadece
bir matematik ifadelerin ötesinde kültür
yaratan bir etkiye sahip olma
potansiyeli olan bir matematik ifade
Çünkü bu sistem bize herhangi bir
bağlantısallık ağı içerisindeki geleceğe
dönük olarak nasıl bir enformasyon
bütünlüğü oluşturabileceğini anlatan bir
formül Yani birinci kuş ikinci ile nasıl
bir etkileşim halinde ikinci bir
milyoncuyla nasıl bir etkileşim halinde
olduğunu bize söyleyen bir formül ve
Paris'i bununla geçen sene ödül aldı
Aldı Nobel ödülünü aldı Çünkü bunu
bazı Demir ve bakır alımlarına
uyguladığı için
Ama bu seneki Nobel ödülleri de bütün
son dönemdeki bütün matematik ödülleri
bu enformasyon matematiğine veriliyor
size bir başka şey göstereyim bu 3 gün
önce çıkan önemli bir yazı Burada
gördüğünüz bir hücre kültürü bu hücre
kültüründe nöronlar 800 bin nöron var bu
800.000 nöronunu yani az önceki
34.000'de 800.000 nöronunu bir hücre
kültürü ortamına koyuyorsunuz bir süre
sonra bunlar Burada gördüğünüz gibi
bağlantı sağlık ağları oluşturuyorlar
Ama
buradaki nöronları eğitebiliyorsunuz
Aynen işte o
1970'lerdeki o Pong diye bir oyun vardı
ya o pank oyununu oynamayı öğreniyor bu
800.000 ve bunu öğrenmesi aşağı yukarı 5
dakika falan oluyor 5 dakika sonra
baya ustalaşıyor ve şurada gördüğünüz o
çalışmanın videosu bu 800.000 nöron bu
bağlantısallık ağı içerisinde bilgi
işleyebilir hale geliyor bir modelleme
oluşturuyor Dolayısıyla artık bu
enformasyon sistemi Az önce rönesans'ta
kaldık ve onun yeni döneminden
bahsediyoruz Ben oradan devam edeyim
bakın
Aristoteles İsa'dan 350 sene önce
çıkıyor diyor ki benim bir elimde 10
kilogramlık Demir diğerinde 1
kilogramlık Demir olsa ben ikisini aynı
anda yere bıraksam 10 kilogramlık yere
ağır olduğu için önce çarpar ve
İnsanoğlu buna 2000 sene inanıyor bu
tümdengelim tümdengelimin en önemli iki
tane sözcüğü var biri varsayım diğeri
kabulleniş ve ta ki galile'ye kadar
galile gerçekten 1600 yılında Pizza
kulesine çıkıyor ve 1 kilogramda 10
kilogramlık Demir aynı anda bırakıyor ve
diyor ki; Aristoteles yanılabilir
Çünkü bakıyor ki İkisi aynı anda yere
çarpıyor ve insanoğlunun o
kabullenişinden sıyrılmasını sağlıyor Ne
ile o varsayımı hipoteze dönüştürerek ve
o hipotezi test ederek onun doğruluğunu
ya da yanlışlığını yeterince test
ettikten sonra ortaya koyuyor ve
Rönesans ortaya çıkıyor işte bu bilimsel
temel Yani benim
newtont kültürü dediğim bu uygarlığımızı
yaratan sistem böyle
bugünün temelleri atılıyor Tabi ki
bununla uğraştığımız bu uygarlık
yaratabildiğimiz en üst uygarlık ama
Geldiğimiz noktada tıkanıklıklarımız var
ve bu tıkanıklıklara işte
nörobilimin bir yanıtı var çünkü esas
gerçek devrimciler bilim insanlarıdır bu
işin unutulmasın her ne kadar bu
devrimlere çoğu zaman siyasetçiler
komutanlar falan sahiplenseler de esas
iyiliği yaratanlar bilim insanlarıdır ve
nörobilimin bize Şu anda sunduğu bir şey
var nörobilin şu anda yeni bir katman
olarak tümdengelimin üzerine eklemlenmiş
tümevarımın üzerine eklemlenmekte olan
bir bağlantısallık bilimi getiriyor ve
bu bağlantı Sağlık bilimi sadece
nörobilimi değiştirmiyor edebiyatı da
değiştiriyor sanatı da değiştiriyor az
önce konuştuk dijital teknolojiyi
değiştiriyor Bizim kendimize
yanımızdakine ve yaşama bakışımızı
değiştiriyor ve bunun en önemli
gerekliliği şu; her şey içinde bulunduğu
aile anlamlı bu bu bizim var olan
kültürümüzde sahip olmak kültürümüzde
bizim kabullenişimiz yaşamın insan için
olduğudur Halbuki beyin çalışmalarından
biz anlıyoruz ki beyin nöron için değil
nöron beyin için yaşam insan için değil
İnsan yaşam için Rönesans'ın
getirdiklerinin yanında bir tek
götürdükleri var Rönesans insan Merkezi
bir kültür yaratmıştır bugüne kadar
ama insan merkezli kültür yerine bizim
yavaş yavaş zihnimizi yaşam odaklı bir
yapıya
ulaştırmamız gerekir
burada birikiyor bir iki ilginç örnek
size göstereceğim Bakın bu bilgi işleyen
bir sistem 383 nöronlu Bir solucan deney
solucanı Bu deneyin solucanının
akvaryumunun kenarına
bir yiyecek maddesi koyuyorsunuz Burası
1 nöron 2 nöron 3 nöronun 1 saniye 2
saniyedeki verdiği kararlar
ve bu algoritmayı birazdan göreceksiniz
bir Lego robotu veriyorsunuz 383 nöron
olduğu için robotu sistemde basit ve bu
bu bilgiyi ve aktardığınız zaman artık
bu Lego aynen bu deney solucanının
verdiği kararların benzerini aynısını
benzerinin aynısını vermeye başlıyor
yani
bilgi işleyen sistemler bu işletim
sistemi açısından içinde bulundukları
organizmadan bağımsızlar yani zeka onu
üreten organizmaya ait bir şey değil
zeka yaşama ait olan bir şey Dolayısıyla
bu esasında bu esasında 80'lerin
ortalarından biri yapay zekiyecilerden
bir tarafından bilinen bir şey bunu
tekrarlamam lazım yani her bilgi işleyen
sistem Eğer ya da geçecek yer üretiyor
ve üretilen zeka onu üreten organizmaya
ait bir şey değil yaşamın bütünlüğüne
ait olan bir şey ve nörobilin bize bunu
öğretiyor bakın burada
bu da bir başka ne içeriyorsa Burada
gördüğünüz ilk sinema filminin
rna'ya rna'ya DNA'ya dönüşüyor Aynen bir
virüs gibi bu bir bakteriyi aktarılıyor
bakteri sonsuz üremeye bırakılıyor ve 25
nesil sonra bu kez Genom tekrar elde
ediliyor dna'dan
bu kez
Sağdaki görüntü elde ediliyor
yani görün oradaki
[Müzik]
birbirinin aynısı yani
yaşam dediğimiz bu enformasyon bütünlüğü
iç içe geçmiş bir kodlamalar sistemi
bütünlüğü ve bu kodlamalar birbirine
dönüşebiliyorlar onlu sistem ikili
sisteme zaten biliyoruz dönüşüyor ama
RNA dönüşüyor bu
yaşamın her katmanında böyle
sona doğru yaklaşırken şunu size
göstermek istiyorum parayı Sizden
aldığım bir slayt burada üst üste konmuş
41 çift dirsekli sarkaç var bunu çift
dirsekte sarkaçları 41 sarkacı sonsuz
salınıma bıraktığınız zaman her
seferinde farklı bir patenle sona eriyor
ve biz işte bu enformasyon matematiğiyle
Bunların ne şekilde sonuçlanacağını
biliyoruz yani elinize 41 nöron düşünün
mesela 41 nöronun bağlantısı sağlığı ya
da bunu geçin 41 öğrencili bir ilkokul
sınıfı düşünün ve 25 sene sonra bir
araya geldiklerini düşünün kırmızı
öğrenciyle yeşil öğrencinin mor
öğrenciyle diğerinin bağlantısallık
paternini düşünün işte bunun matematiği
var Ve bunu bize nöronel sistemler
öğretiyorlar bunun adı otopoyazzez yani
her sistem yeteri kadar bilgiyi işediği
zaman zeka öğretiyor işte bir bütünün
onu oluşturan parçaların alternatif
toplamından fazla olmasını sağlayan şey
işte bu otopoozis dediğimiz
termodinamiğin ikinci yasasına uymayan
uymayan o fazlalıktan geliyor Bunu ilk
fark eden kim shrodinger
1943'te yaşam nedir diye sorduğu zaman
bunu söylüyordu diyordu ki Bir inorganik
Evren var bir bu organik bir Evren
yaratıyor hücre evreni yaratıyor organ
evreni yaratıyor ama termodinamik ikinci
yasasına göre bunun olmaması lazım Ve
bugün Artık biliyoruz ki enformasyon
işleyen sistemler termodinamiğin ikinci
yasasına uymuyorlar ve bu önemli bir
farklılık Çünkü her bilgi işleyen sistem
her yerde geç zeka öğretiyor bakın
Burada gördüğünüz tek bir Kök hücreden
üreyen bir milyon Yani bir leblebi bir
tanesi büyüklüğünde bir organına ait
minibeyi bunları biz 2016'dan beri
laboratuvarda saklıyoruz gerekirse
bunların üzerine çalışıyoruz 2018'e
büyük Üniversitesinde bir şey keşfedildi
çok ilginç
yani zeka yaratıyor ve ürettiği heykel
dalgası anne karnında büyümeye çalışan
embriyonun beyniyle aynı evege dalgası
acayip bir şey
Dolayısıyla
zeka enformasyon işleyen sistemler zeka
üretiyorlar ve üretilen zeka onu üreten
organizmadan bağımsız bir şey
ve bu bize yeni bir kültürü açıyor bu
kültürün adını Şimdilik işte Daha iyisi
bulana kadar yaşamdaşlık adını veriyoruz
yaşamdaşlık kültüründeki en önemli öğeye
yaşamın insan için olduğu değil insanın
yaşam için oldu buradaki enformasyon
ağını oluşturan her şey bu bütünlük için
ve oluşan böyle Dolayısıyla Burada
en önemli işin başlangıç noktası merak
bizim var olan kültürümüzde Çalışkan
olmak ve Zeki olmak gereğinden fazla
kutsanmış iki özelliktir Tabii ki
Çalışkan olmak ve Zeki olmak çok önemli
ama artık bu yeni yaşamdaşlık kültüründe
bu bağlantısallık biliminde esas olan
merak iyilik ve yaratıcılık Zaten
bugünkü konuşmalarda en çok sözü edilen
şeylerde bunlardı Tabii Burada hep
zihinden bahsettim bile bilinç var
bilinç anlamlandırmayla alakalı bir şey
onu bir başka Tetik konuşmasında Belki
konuşuruz eğitimini değiştiren bir şey
bu neden eğitimi değişmiş bizim var Olan
eğitimimiz buradaki gibi bu tavuğun
eğitimi gibi bir şey bu ortada bir pembe
halka var bu pembe daireyi gagaladığı
zaman biz eğitimden bunu öğreniyoruz
zannediyoruz ki o test sorularını
çözmekle hep o arpayı alacağız Halbuki
bu Aa bu asal Yapı bu enformasyon
sistemi başka renklerin olduğunu da bize
gösteriyor merak burada çok önemli merak
o o örümcek ağı gibi olan o zihninin
örümcek ağını oluşturan eteğin kendisi O
merak
sandığımızdan önemli bir şey ee o yüzden
bu konuşmada altını çizmek gerekir tek
bir sözcük versem meraktır esasında ve
Bu anlayış bizim yaşama bakışımızı
değiştirdi mi Vallahi nöro bilimcileri
olarak bizim yaşamama bakışımızı çok
değiştirdi Aynen Renk körü olan
birisinin renk körlüğünün düzeltilmesi
gibi Renk körü olanlar renk kör
olduklarını bilmezler ta ki renk
körlükleri düzeltilinceye kadar veren
körlüğü düzeltilince Aynen buradaki
çocuğun kırmızıyı gördüğü zaman
hissettiği gibi
anlar ki kırmızı artık
bildiği kırmızı değil mavi bildiğim abi
değil işte bugünkü konuşmaları Ben de
bunu hissettim o yüzden çok teşekkür
ederim Ali Bey'e bitmedi
bitmedi Dolayısıyla Bu bize yeni bir
uygarlığın kapılarını açıyor ben
sizin zihninizin alanlarını bu yeni
Uygarlığa açmanızı çok istiyorum çünkü
gerçekten nasıl daha iyi ve güzel bir
dünya yaratabiliriz sorusuna biz bu
alanda samimi yanıtlar bulabiliriz Bakın
bu önemli bir Metamorfoz önemli bir
dönüşüm Aynen tırtılın kelebek olması
gibi biliyorsunuz tırtılla kelebek aynı
gene yapısına sahip ikisiningen yapısı
aynı ama ve her tırtıldan da malumunuz
kelebek olmuyor bir tırtılın kelebek
olabilmesi için
yaşamayı Seçen hücrelerinin bir eşik
değeri var O nedenle Herkes çok önemli
yani Ee 999 işe yaramaz da bir fazlası
Türkiye'yi de dönüştürür dünyayı da
dönüştürür Burayı da dönüştürür O yüzden
herkes herkes çok önemli
Bu nedenle ben buradaki toplantı için
çok teşekkür ediyorum ve her Birinizin
Gelecekte
bir tırtıldan güzel birer kelebeğe
dönüşebileceği inancıyla bu konuşmayı
bitiriyorum teşekkürler
[Alkış]
[Müzik]